this next email comes from Kylee Ross's
wife did everyone write a [ __ ] email
[Music]
yours is special Ralphy Kevin my rub my
husband Ross already emailed you about
us being there for his birthday but I
decided to email you as well because we
got you presents you should definitely
read my email one so I can give you the
presents too because I'm wearing a good
cleavage shirt we'll be the judge of
that Kylie that is a pretty good good
cleavage shirt you have presents this
one's a heaven what is a pitch it up
here man that's a little a little a
little a chain that is a there's a
life-size Kevin Smith [ __ ] feature look
at that these are [ __ ] straws for Kevin
to put in his delicious tasting Arnold
Palmer I will use this right now oh
don't put a cop straw you drink [ __ ]
novelty this young has a you thoughtful
and practical yes oh thank you I like
that it is a clown hand puppet and the
only thing creepier than actual clouds
in my opinion are clown puppets
[Laughter]
look at this we could do anatomically
correct clown now that's scary clown
they can blow himself we should make
this mandatory people have to bring a
[ __ ] every child this is amazing thank
you thank you for the gifts Kylie we
appreciate ya thank you for your ample
bosom as well / mind this [ __ ] boring
old straw
you've got the expandable [ __ ] straw you
should do a late night TV infomercial a
mother swallower are you tired drinking
out of the same old straws try new Kevin
Smith [ __ ] straws it's delicious we hit
big chocolate milk tastes better couple
of nine-year-olds makes fizzy drinks
cheesy drinks come one come on
water now I'll get the new ball cups
[Music]
you